hey guys Pete here it's time for the
weekly spoiler report an interesting mix
of news was reported around the filming
locations and we got some exciting set
pictures from Belfast also a deleted
scene from season six came out and the
first history and lore clip from the
upcoming Game of Thrones season 6 DVD
collection warning for spoilers this
video will contain news related to the
filming of Game of Thrones season 7
including stuff that can spoil the
stories of the main characters if you
don't want potential clues for what
might happen in season 7 this video
isn't for you I do have a book giveaway
going on right now though so if you're
leaving check out the non spoilers Nissa
Nissa video I put out this week and if
you're staying stick around until the
end to learn about how to enter that's
your warning so let's get started gone
are the days of the wide-open shots of
the cast and crew filming in last week's
video I talked about a huge scene with
almost all the main characters together
in one place and this week we have more
information about it
last Saturday Watchers on the wall
sources told of Lena Headey Peter
Dinklage Emilia Clarke Kit Harington Ian
Glen Conleth Hill
Natalie Emmanuel Anton lesser Rory
McCann and the mountain whose name looks
pretty hard to pronounce but I'll give
it a shot
Hathor bjornsen okay yeah those guys
were all filming together at Italica
this much we already knew but they are
now saying that they can confirm that
the film scene involves characters
bringing a white into the dragon pit as
proof of the white Walker threat for
those of you who are fans of the
possible plot leaked you'll see this is
validation that it's real and the rest
of us who are skeptical will continue to
wait and see you know as our position
has been either way this comes from good
sources / Watchers on the wall so I tend
to believe that this is what brought
this unprecedented group of characters
together cleganebowl advocates won't
have missed that both brothers were
involved in filming this scene but there
are no reports of them fighting at all
at this point we didn't really get any
more news from the seville set but we
did get loads of cast pictures most of
the cast involved with this scene went
out with dan and dad to see an
association football match but
the local team in Barcelona the cast in
D&D looked like they're having a great
time together well that was going on a
minor recurring character that I talked
about a few videos back showed up in
Seville the little bird called Francis
played by Annette Hanna was spotted by
fans remember the first photo we saw of
her was in Belfast and they are shooting
the season finale at Seville this brings
up speculation about whether the little
bird is truly loyal to Qyburn or if she
will work with her previous master Varys
she has mentioned missing her old master
to Qyburn but she was still involved in
the killing of pycelle I think there's a
pretty strong chance since we know Varys
will be in King's Landing for this scene
that he will look to his little birds to
learn important information that the
Targaryen faction can use to their
advantage while filming was wrapping up
at the main dragon pit and the royal
ship yards at Seville the crew started
prepping trujillo castle for filming
this coming week as you can see in the
photo this is a cool-looking castle but
initial reports say that the shooting is
only going to be in the inner courtyard
nearby who is reporting that rehearsals
are getting underway for the big scene
I've mentioned in several of my spoilers
videos
I won't retell the whole story here so
check out my spoilers playlists for more
info on that if you want to if you want
to learn about this is the singing that
will be the largest action scene in a
season 7 and the one where they have a
hundred horses and tons of extras that
they're giving military training to
shooting in the area is supposed to run
for three weeks with at least one dragon
two armies and plenty of key characters
early rumors said that one of Tyrion
siblings would be involved and I think
we can say now that it's going to be
Jamie I say this because Jerome Flynn
who plays bran has already been spotted
in the area since we know that both
Jamie and Sir Bronn of the Blackwater
are supposed to be included in the big
season finale scene I talked about last
week it's probably a good guess that
they both make it out of season sevens
major battle scene alive from Seville we
learned that shooting lasted a little
longer than originally reported and that
many of the characters who were still
there would be headed to Belfast rather
than to the big battle scene I just
mentioned the final scenes included Lena
Headey Kit Harington Gwendoline Christie
liam Cunningham and Rory McCann for sure
as per reports these actors would be
headed to Belfast rather than the next
site in Spain after seeing Bronn and
Casares another actor showed up ahead of
filming James Faulkner who plays randyll
Tarly is in town which would make sense
considering his character's military
prowess
it's not a hundred percent clear yet
which scenes he'll be involved in so
hopefully we'll get more information
about that once things get rolling
Watchers on the wall also got some news
about set preparation and Iceland
there's a construction crew building
what looks to be like an icy passage
which locals nearby say is for Game of
Thrones
since there's talk of going north of the
wall to bring back that white for the
season finale this area could be
involved the big battle scene has been
rumoured to occur near castle which a
lot of us expected would be Highgarden
the home of the Tyrells
once again the Watchers folks confirmed
this week that Highgarden would be
included in season 7 but also the
Casterly Rock home of the Lannisters is
also confirmed to be one of the seasons
locations they say there will be at
least two eventful scenes around these
locations and this is exciting news
which I hope we'll learn more about once
filming gets underway a full week before
shooting starts on the ambush scene l
para o T Co Extremadura
is already getting images of the
preparations as previously reported we
see that horses are on hand for that
military training that the 500 extras
are supposed to be getting we also got
an image of the crew testing smoke
machines which adds to the height battle
of the bastard style and randyll Tarly
gave us another shot on horseback which
is a good clue that he'll be charging
into battle if only without his houses
Valyrian steel blade Hart's Bane
the Royal shipyard filming happened
without much additional information
slipping out there were shots of the
cruise trucks seen nearby and we learned
that Cersei and Qyburn were the
characters involved this could be a
meeting between the two either before
the large group scene or after no way to
tell for sure that was the end of the
Seville shooting and most of the cast
moved on but not before buying all the
fans camped outside the hotel some pizza
a video was posted on Instagram that
showed Dan Weiss David Benioff Kit
Harington Rory McCain and other cast
members took ten boxes of pizza to the
crowd of 50 fans after that we started
to get photos from Belfast
tormund Giantsbane posted a photo on his
Instagram account from there and then we
got a fan shot with her in Aria a little
bit later we got a shot of tormance
beard with a hint of snow and a hashtag
that read behind the scenes no telling
if tormund Aria and Jon Snow are
shooting in the same scenes since they
shoot their studio scenes there you know
they're giant studio is located in
Belfast from the snow and the beard
torment maybe shooting outside but
there's really no direct news about it
all we know for sure is that all three
actors are in the same part of the world
at the end of the week when it looked
like things might be cooling down two
new photos of sets from Belfast popped
up apparently a programmer working on
the production of Game of Thrones got a
chance to visit Titanic Studios a couple
weeks ago he managed to snap two awesome
photos for him inside which is a rare
occurrence but then he posted them to
his Twitter account where it seems they
went to notice for a little while the
first photo is the Iron Throne in King's
Landing with one major alteration in the
background we see them instead of the
seven-pointed star Cersei has installed
the Lannister line this leaves no doubt
that she isn't looking to make peace
with the faith after destroying the
great set the second photo is probably
the most exciting thing I saw this week
it's a throne we never seen before and
contains a clue that confirms it's
dragons - this is Queen Daenerys is
throne without a doubt the rock
formation behind the seat is known as a
flesh a layer type of sedimentary rocks
we saw this at Zumaya where they shocked
some of the dragon stone scenes and they
also built additional formations to add
to the scenery those ents Raynaud's
posted this stock photograph to show
that this is exactly what the crew was
to recreate this is really cool looking
and hints and hints at the intentions of
Westeros as latest invader how else can
you have the leaders and Lords bend the
knee if you don't have a proper throne
to receive them from I don't know about
you guys but this gets me hyped up
that's about it for set news and
spoilers as mentioned there was a
deleted scene from season 6 with the
Queen of thorns and her son mace Tyrell
that Entertainment Weekly put out it's
not an essential scene but it's funny
and well worth watching you can watch it
on the e W website if you want to check
it out my favorite part is her pressing
mace about if he was singing in Bravos
there was also a sneak peek at the
upcoming history and lore series that
will be included with the season 6 DVD
set the first episode is called the
children of the forest versus the first
men and is narrated by the three-eyed
Raven actor maxim and sit down it's
pretty great like the rest of the
history and lore clips and you can check
it out on the io9 website in full for
free they also have a list of all 18
clips that make up the DVD extras for
the season 6 set I'll put an Amazon link
in the description for the DVDs they're
gonna be shipping on the 15th of this
month which is just a couple days after
I make this video I think I might make a
video about the one that's out there now
so let me know if you have any questions
about that battle or how that all went
down after you watch it please like the
video if you enjoyed it and please
subscribe to my channel you can follow
me on all the social networks that are
listed in the description of this video
or you can click the links in the
description on my channels main page as
mentioned I've started a new book
giveaway this time when I hit 28,000
subscribers I'll pick one commenter and
send them a copy of the new 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
I'll put an Amazon link in the
description of this video so you can
check out the book if you haven't seen
it yet cuz it's pretty cool all you have
to do is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video and/or any other
video where I mentioned this giveaway to
enter to see how the whole picking
process goes down you can check out my
Dragonstone video where I picked the
winner of the last
give away thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon